this started out as a joke for me i
stole a quarter from my mother
that's how it starts like my mother had
a bar she used to have change
and when you're a kid you take like a
quarter and you're like it's okay you
know it's just a [__] quarter but
that's how this [__] starts
and i would never steal from my mother i
love my mother but that's you don't even
know you're doing it
you're compromising your [__]
character and then i moved to new jersey
where larceny
it's in the [__] air everybody's a
larcenist
because the first thing you do in jersey
is buy stolen stuff
everybody what do you need a toast i'll
be here tomorrow about four o'clock have
the cash money bro
you know and people show up like i got
you that refrigerator it's 852 new
give me 400 and we'll [__] rock the
house brand new in a box with
so even though you're buying this [__]
you're not stealing it you're still
compromising your character
you know and then you get i was like in
the eighth grade and you know you [__]
around you steal
papers then we robbed the van for the
comic books one day we didn't drive it
we [__] drove it a little bit and we
couldn't drive because we were too
stupid and scared
so we it had comic books and t-shirts
and that's how it starts it's a [__]
joke
but where i grew up in jersey these
[__] were little hustlers i
didn't call it steel and it was hustling
these guys would walk miles into the
norton the meadowlands where the
meadowlands is now
and steal these [__] things called
punks and you lit them and
and the mosquitoes would go away and
then when that got bored there was a
train that used to run through the
aerial lackawanna
and then you we used to [__] say
let's rob it because it used to stop and
and then have to change [__] things
so we'd go break seals and there was
always [__] we couldn't carry like an
oven or
but then one day we busted into them
they were little motorcycles
that were unbuilt little honda mini
trails they were three speed with no
[__] clutch tremendous
tremendous if you're [__] you know
what i'm saying you
i can't get this clutch thing there
ain't no clutch [__]
three down one back you're in you don't
even need a helmet
and we would take them and throw them
off then you had to get one of your
brother's older friends to drive back
down and put them in the car and take
them
but these little things this is and you
i didn't think nothing of it like it was
just hustling you know what i'm saying
then i remembered i had these friends
lamenka and these little puerto rican
dudes
and they were stone cold house thieves
in the seventh grade
like these [__] are breaking
into you know you do your homework at
three not these [__]
they went terrorizing and one day they
came home like oh you have a great house
on your block let's burglarize and i'm
like you know what
i always wanted to be kind of a burglar
because
that's beside wanting to shoot people i
wanted to be a burglar too
because when i was a kid one of my
babysitters in manhattan was this chick
she was a cuban chinese chick her name
was latina
i forget what her real name was but
that's what we call the latina
and the husband's name was mongito he
was a cuban dude but he was a burglar
and how i knew was because he used to
teach me how to file the [__]
he would get those things to to measure
your spark plug with
and he'd file him down and he could pick
[__] locks and he used to teach me
here i am five and [__] he would teach
me
and if i did good he would give me
vanilla wafers and orange soda and we
would eat and watch like [__]
that's better than a star on your
forehead you know what i'm saying
and years later i've been asking my mom
what have happened to him he's like that
guy got caught robin mayor koch's house
that's how much of a [__] burglar
this guy was he was the real [__]
deal
so and then there was a show called the
takes the thief when i was a kid way
before none of your [__] came
around with robert conrad
when he was a pimp i think it was robert
conrad and this guy used to rob some
[__] so i always wanted to be like a
high level thief
then i seen the thief with james khan
and it was all over
and willie nelson it was all [__]
over after that i was robbing
[__] that's
it so he comes over one day la mega guy
goes let's rob that house
people were moving into the house and he
wanted to rob it as they were moving in
from the lookout and they come back and
we got your stereo
those old stereos with the cassette and
the eight track and you had the [__]
album with the speakers and if you went
like this only one speaker played and
[__]
a whole a lot of love sounded [__] up
that type of [__] don't embarrass me
guys i'm up here playing speaker joe all
over the [__] side
so i remember they gave me this the
stereo i brought it home into my bedroom
i got a stereo
the kid moved and i liked the [__]
kid he was a little puerto rican kid
and i liked him he was great at
basketball he would come over for
kool-aid and he'd go let's go up to your
room and listen to music we can't
how come my mom don't want no boys in
the [__] room that's why
because i had stolen his [__] stereo
i couldn't have him up in the [__]
room now
he would have said that's my stereo so
for two years i hung out with this kid i
wouldn't allow him in my [__] bedroom